hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse sorry about that I'm two
minutes late this is two days in a row
I'm late I was having some technical
difficulties so the stream the stream
wouldn't start it was entirely my fault
though is user error so also I was
trying to finish off the done up before
the stream started I almost did it
there's like maybe two bites left so
today is probably going to be a really
short stream less than an hour there's a
non mandatory event going on at 3:00 I
still haven't decided in entirely
whether or not I'm gonna go I probably
should go but to be honest I felt like
I'm gonna have a panic attack for the
last hour I'm not exactly sure why I
just I think I just have a lot of stuff
going on right now
and time's running out so streaking me
out a little bit so I'd rather have a
panic attack in my office and then have
a panic attack in front of the entire
university so we'll see
maybe I'll go maybe I won't I'm thinking
thy screaming will help me take my mind
off of everything and feel better so I
haven't had a panic attack in a really
long time so I don't I don't think it'll
happen
we'll see enough about my mental health
let's get started I've chosen today to
work on some easy stuff you know just
some basic UI things I I had some other
ideas I wanted to get started on the
authentication but I don't think I have
enough information yet to really get
started I've been waiting back to hear
back from someone in the IT department
let's see I just got an email back from
some I'm looking at it right now so okay
I'm gonna have to review that a little
bit a little bit better after the stream
but all right so let's let's get started
let's let's do some work on this and
I've gotten a lot of pool requests so I
think what I'll do is I'd like to get
just get started and get to work and
then maybe we'll see if we have some
time we can review the pool request
later on in the stream I really
appreciate everybody submitting requests
I had some some new people who've never
submitted pool requests before to the
projects and that's awesome so thanks
and I'm gonna keep putting up issues so
I've already got up more issues I think
maybe I think like seven new issues
maybe maybe less than seven and you all
are awesome it's it's like as soon as I
post the issues someone's saying hey
I'll I'll take that one so that's great
so let me show you first what we're
gonna work on and then we'll do it and
I'll start my timer so if you're new to
the show the timer is to kind of break
things up a little bit so we'll do 25
minutes of coding and then we'll take a
five-minute break and I'll go to the
live chat and answer any questions that
you all have and then we'll go back and
forth like that and and then at the end
of the stream if there are any questions
that I couldn't get to which usually
happens then I'll get to all the
questions so if you have asked something
and I'm not getting to it right away
just be patient and I will get to it
before I am the stream okay so this is
what I want to work on so I this
particular page
really obvious that I need some work
with UI so one of the recent changes is
this is now a link which obviously has
changed the style so we want to change
this obviously I don't want it to be
this color I don't want the underline
underneath actually I don't even want it
to be that font that's kind of odd yeah
so a lot has to change so font font has
to change across the board in font size
a lot of things positioning has to
change in this particular case there's
no image uploaded so I don't even want
there to be an image here I'm also
considering adding some margins in I
don't know it's not obvious in this post
but if we can find another post let's
find one with some some more text
content you know in this case that it
doesn't really look great to have you
know have this text all the way across
like that so I think we have two options
the first option which will probably try
out is if we make this font larger it
may not look quite as bad because there
won't be so many characters across one
line or potentially we could add some
margins and on the sides and then there
won't be so many characters on one line
the solution is probably going to end up
being a mix of both we'll see so those
are my main the main things that I'd
like to change I do want to show you how
I displayed single posts on the current
version of this so let's see I just
noticed Sebastian's question at the
bottom a live chat here asking why do
you want that as a link you are already
in the post yes so I actually didn't
request that to be a link it was just
added in on the pool request that made
so what I wanted was this
to be a link these titles and then that
was just added in I left it in there for
now because it's not for right now it's
not hurting anything I know I have seen
it before particularly with some
WordPress sites that it does act like
that that the title was always a link no
matter what I was going to give it
I just merge this pull request a little
a little while ago today so I was going
to give it some time to think if there
would be a good use case for that link
before I take it out if I can't think of
anything within the next day or two I
probably will take it out but for now I
need to style that title anyway even
before it was a link I wanted to restyle
it so it's not really going to be that
big of a deal for now so if anybody can
think of a use case where we would
actually want that to be a link let me
know I'm having trouble thinking of it
so otherwise I will I will take that out
but in that case I liked what was done
in the pull request it met all the
requirements for that issue so I wanted
to go ahead and merge it anyway even
though it had that as well in there so
so that's that's why so let's see oh I
see several reviewers saying that today
is Diwali hopefully I'm pronouncing that
right so I'm not I'm actually not
familiar with Diwali so harsh it says
it's like Christmas here so I don't know
what the appropriate greeting is so I'll
just say you know okay it's happy do all
right so happy Diwali to everyone and so
for those of you that celebrate that I
hope you have a great time okay it's a
festival in India cool so I'm just I'm
just gonna
wish you all a happy time there so I
don't really know that much about it so
I don't want to be offensive or say
something silly about it I limit my
comments to that so there's not really a
big Indian population where I live so
I'm not I'm not that familiar with with
Indian customs so so sorry for my
ignorance in that area
let's see but I know I I do have quite a
few viewers from India so so I hope
everyone has a good time
hey it's a festival of lights cool that
sounds cool lots of lights and
firecrackers cool that sounds pretty
awesome alright maybe I'll have to look
up something after the stream about it
let's see I guess I checked they're not
need to figure out what I was doing ok
yeah so we basically gone over oh I know
what I was gonna show you sorry I was
going to show you how how I'm doing this
now with the current bulletin but V aam
says please say my name so the young
child re I'm really sorry if I'm
mispronouncing that I'm sure I am but vo
um
there you go I said your name thanks for
watching thanks for being in the live
Shack and I'll see this is I'm on Chrome
Canary in this window and I'm not signed
in so let me let me go to my other
browser window inside since I'm already
signed in there this is just regular
Chrome
there we go alright so this is how I'm
displaying things here it's actually in
a modal the URL does change
so each one of these has its own URL but
it's displayed as a modal so I don't
exactly have the same issues since it's
not an entirely different page the
reason I did this in a modal is because
I wanted to allow users to keep their
place you know we have an infinite
scroll implemented so if users are
scrolling for a really long time I
didn't want their place to get lost so
that's why I ended up doing it like this
so I think that's still important if
there's a way to let a user keep their
place so that when they go back so for
instance here right we've we've gone to
another page if we could go back and
have them keep their place I'm okay with
with having it on its separate separate
page that's oh that was actually my
first choice for the original version of
the bulletin but like I said I changed
it for that reason so they could keep
their place so let's see how I should
keep saying PR 39 all right I haven't
checked if you submitted a PR within the
last hour I haven't looked at it yet so
I guess I could take a look at PR 39
right now and see what's in
let me see what your 13 item back
in-house okay you know what hard [ __ ] I
did see this one I didn't get to go
through everything with it but I can see
so I did see that that will probably be
merged in at some point probably
tomorrow so I'll get that merged in
Sunni let me actually let's do it like
this
we could probably test this out so I'm
gonna scroll all the way down I'm gonna
click this and then I'm gonna click back
great we're still in the same spot
awesome so we're good to go with this
for whatever reason the way I built it
the other one it wasn't keeping a user's
place so I don't know I don't know what
was going on that's a big mess of jQuery
for the other one so I'm not even going
to try to figure out what I was doing so
anyway we're good to go for for this so
let's just start out with the title and
work our way down and clean this up a
bit okay we got I have quite a few
things open let me get rid of some of
these as I can barely read the I can
barely read what these are I have too
many open post preview no I don't want
the preview with the detail all right so
we want to we're gonna be on post detail
I do want to let you all know as well
that I added a new repository oh cool
and rock let me get the end rock started
thanks art [ __ ] for reminding me that
there we go and if you're not familiar
with end rock I'm about to paste a link
in the live chat you can go to that link
and see the site on your your own
browser and inspect it as we work on it
you'll see changes live so there we go
there's a link in there and I could see
a lot of connections happening so that's
working
I added a new repository on my github
profile so not the fus Markham profile
and it's a flashcard I think the
repositories just called flashcards and
that is my first react native app so if
anybody's interested in react native you
can check that out it's not finished yet
so you can't like clone that and have
something that's you know ready to go
but it has a lot of boilerplate that
should work and whenever I'm finished
with it oh I'll go over that in a stream
and that's that's my final project for
the Udacity react nanodegree so just
thought I'd put that out there in case
anybody's interested I know we haven't
actually done any streams of react
native but I some of you have asked
about it so there's something for now
we'll have more on it
I don't know when but definitely gonna
work with it more because it's pretty
cool so let's see now we don't want to
get all it down to the drawer there no
I'm on the wrong component how did I get
there
sorry about that it looked like I
wondered why all that stuff was in there
okay let me make this a bit bigger for
you all if you can see and we'll close
that side panel there we don't need that
okay let's you see we should be bringing
in the correct font let me see where
we're bringing it in
I believe we're using the correct font
here we are so
how are we using this one let's see
it's not once
well I want to look at the post preview
briefly and see how we're doing it there
- my components there there
okay so we must we're bringing in
typography okay typography type headline
all right I knew there was a special
component I was pretty sure was
typography but I wanted to double check
so we need to use this and I don't think
I've actually worked with this myself
yet so it it seems like we just need to
wrap all of our text with typography and
just give it a type depending on what
the text is supposed to do okay that's
what we will do then
so on our post detail there's your title
whoops did I bring that in
actually let me see did we come to some
consensus as to whether or not we should
keep that link in okay I forgot about
that API server
alright so sorry for those of you who
are trying to use an gerak and it's not
working I didn't even think about it so
harsh that says please start the backend
server in hendrik and use its length
okay we're going to start
who was that port 8 was a port 8080 I
think that was it so yeah let's start
that
actually how however the hell is this
gonna work I'm gonna need to start am I
going to need to start both servers and
end grok and then and then change the
links right
hmm this might be a little bit more
tricky then how about this for now just
to simplify it let's do it like this and
we're
so I'm going to use this link
oops what just happened
why does it keep going to drawer
why
[Music]
all right I'm just gonna do this for now
I'm not gonna yeah I'm definitely not
gonna commit this so this is just
temporary just so that it works because
I don't I want to get to what I would
like to do for this dream so I'm gonna
we'll have a better solution at some
point but for now that should work so
let me know if it's not working I think
that should work though okay and it
looks like I've gotten some responses
here about keeping or not keeping that
link so let's go ahead and just take out
the link now since we're already in here
let's get rid of it
oops
let's copy where to go
we had our post preview let's copy the
same headline at least go with type
headline and component h2
and we don't have these classes set up
yet so we'll probably use this class but
for now it won't see it we got it just
put this actually do I want that's being
h1 let's leave that page for a second
what kind of tag do we have listen we
have that in an h1 I'm gonna put this in
an h2 I usually only like to have one h1
on a page I might have to look it up and
see what's best for SEO actually it
doesn't matter this is going to be
password protect it's going to be you
have to log in to get to it so I don't
really care about SEO so anyway I guess
it didn't matter but let me get rid of
this link before I forget because we're
not using this yeah we don't have links
anywhere else right now no I don't think
we have any more links okay
so let's save that oh yeah you're right
thanks Sebastian I don't know what I was
thinking
typography does take care of wrapping
that properly so thanks for that okay
okay so they can ipsum and just to
double-check i'm inspect it is wrapped
in an H to my console was quite small
but just to show you it turns it into an
h2 so you don't actually have to put in
an h2 tag you just pass h2 as a prop
like this to typography and typography
does the rest which is pretty cool okay
all right I don't want it to be styled
like that for now for now I'm okay with
that because I want to see how
everything looks in relation to each
other before I start to mess with the
font size here
so now let's maybe we should move the
author and date up here let's try that
and see how that looks actually doing it
author you know what I'm gonna remove
the author because we're never gonna
have any different authors so we
currently don't display authors if we
are setting this up as as a blog then
definitely keep the author in here but
in this case it's not gonna it's not
gonna matter
let's see or take that out but I do want
to bring the date up okay Sebastian is
actually recommending that we try type
display too
okay let's try that out and see what we
get
oh wow big difference okay that's cool
I don't this is not really the look that
I wanted but it's cool that we can get
these so maybe it'll be worth a shot a
little bit later on in the stream to
check out the material UI documentation
and see what kind of built-in styles
they have if we can see see what we have
now I think it's just yeah it's
basically just this blue color really
thin thin font weight and do want to
keep actually we should bring the put
the category up here as well so instead
of author we're gonna pull in the
category and display it and then we're
gonna bring in the date
I'm just looking at harsh it says asks
if we use moment js4 date formatting or
use my hacky date formatting code
actually to be honest with you if the
formatting works I mean this this works
so I'll take a look at the code but if
it works I don't have any problem and
it's not like we're doing anything
really spectacular with the dates we
just need to display it in a readable
way so I don't know if there's any
reason why I should bring in something
like moment J s let me know but it seems
to me like it might be overkill for our
use case if we find that we need some
more functionality in regard to dates
then maybe we'll bring it in but for now
I think this is fine at least it looks
the look of it is is fine
let's see my timer just went off so
that was crazy those like the fastest
time has just been going by really fast
today at least for me it seems like it's
going by really fast I think that's why
part of the reason why I felt like I was
going to have a a panic attack
just a lot of stuff going on that needs
to be done and time is slipping away
alright so I've started my five-minute
timer I must scroll up to the top of the
live chat and answer some questions
after that we'll do a bit more code okay
oh okay Sebastian says found a UI glitch
when you click the three dots icon in
the drop-down appears the text of
bulletin on the app bar moves to the
left okay cool let's check that out
all right let's try it from maybe a
different interesting okay so I'm not
able to recreate that right now maybe
maybe it depends on let's see you in
your 3d icon yeah maybe it depends
somewhat on device I assume you were
looking at it with Chrome as well but
let me know if you haven't already done
this
Sebastian put it in an issue and mention
the device you're on in the browser and
the screen with if you can because
something like this could possibly be
tied into screen with as well and then
we'll see and if anybody else can
recreate that please add to that that
issue on github I don't
I meant issue if I said pull request
another Sebastian sorry about that what
I meant to say was issue yeah so any
laces I can't recreate it right now I
can't really do anything about it but
definitely want to get that fixed
Sebastian says also my PRS is done
almost awesome awesome thank you
okay so as a so it's easy easy sorry if
I'm mispronouncing that let me know how
I should pronounce it but as a says
sorry but what's the project about today
okay so today we're working on this
project that is built with react and it
pulls in basically posts from WordPress
using graph QL and we're pulling that in
with Apollo that's working with react
and we're displaying those posts and
basically this UI setup so today if you
haven't already figured it out we're
just kind of making this UI look a
little bit nicer a little bit more in
line with with our style guide which is
based primarily on material design
okay
okay
haha Erwin says you're getting a phone
call yeah I was you can hear the
vibration yeah it was a spam caller most
likely
okay
I might make it through everything in
the live chat within these five minutes
we'll see oh cool a hard [ __ ] says I
will write an N Grogg script and
package.json ah that's that's really
awesome thank you that would be great
Harshit says he just saw the the commits
for this project and yes and he mentions
he's 13 commits ahead of me and I know I
know you are let's uh whoa
github is not oh I know I get up isn't
the first one here cuz this is Chrome
Canary let's see I need to just not use
Chrome Canary because uh I'm not logged
in on anything than there anyway let me
flash on the screen quickly before we
start the timer again the contribution
stats since since hardship brought it up
I want to give everyone credit who
deserves credit for this bulletin so
here we go
so yes Harshit is number one in commits
and lagging behind is is me number two
so yeah this might be the first time
this is happen I think I have been
passed up briefly on previous projects
but never for more than like a day so
this is unique situation but yeah so
thank you so much hard you're doing a
lot for this project and look at this we
have so many contributors now so I
really appreciate that that's that's
awesome the projects are always so much
better when you all contribute so anyway
thanks for that I'll have to have to get
to work this projects been a little bit
odd in terms of Michael
distribution because I have some other
things that I am working on when I'm not
streaming and for this project I almost
primarily work on it during streams and
I don't do very much at all except
review pull requests when I'm not doing
a stream so that's why there's not quite
as many commits for me on this project
because like I said just because of the
other things that I have to do also
important things but just things that I
don't think would be quite as fun for a
live stream okay
oh okay
let's see Sebastian says that the the
air only happens from the homepage this
is it oops maybe let's try
okay so it must be an eel a Sebastian if
you remember was was getting a kind of a
UI bug here but he was on Windows chrome
so I'm on a Mac right now that possibly
that's that's part of the issue all
right let's go back to one of these here
and let's keep going so let's wrap this
text in typography and see what it looks
like
there we go all right
and was uh I forgot we were gonna change
this weren't we
let's yeah let's move this up so we're
gonna move the date up here and let's
wrap this in typography and what we have
a subheading you have a six a subheading
I'm not sure what that will look like
exactly let's see
component
let's give it I don't want it to be huge
let's try an h4 see how that looks
and now let's paste this in and we don't
need the H tag so let's see how that
looks
oh okay that's that's not far off in
terms of size what I was thinking so not
bad and let's put the kind of in the
same size range as the date we're gonna
put the category up here
yeah let's get rid of that and let me
I'm just gonna copy this for now we'll
probably put some different styles at
some point but for now host I'm not sure
if we're even pulling in any data on
categories
there's a single post t2
let's check our posts no we're not we're
not bringing in any categories so let's
do that here where's our fragments
come on interesting
I thought we were pulling these in how
are we doing this on those preview
because we're not pulling it in there
we're pulling it in further up okay so
what I'm trying to figure out right now
is the best way to pull in category data
into our single post page let's see
thanks honey for reminding me about the
my face blocking the timer so I'm trying
to figure out how we're getting the
categories for the post previews and
would like to do that
the same way for the post otherwise I
mean we could we could certainly just
add it in here to get this but I didn't
want to duplicate work if we're already
doing it so we're we got no I guess
either one of these will work they'll be
bringing it get all posts so we are just
using get all posts all right then
Oh coach I understand
nothing
huh that's odd I really thought I merged
the pool request earlier that was doing
oh you know what I ended up not merging
it let me double check here
yeah we're not it was Sebastian's pool
request and I didn't merge it already I
let me go back to Sebastian's pull
request then let's see
let's check these pull requests here I'm
gonna grab I'm just gonna grab for now
the part of this pull request that that
does that actually let me see wouldn't
you
actually you know what I like this I
like this how this is right now - let me
alright let me say this quickly
actually I don't want to commit this
part so I'm just gonna commit let me
pull over my my terminal so we can see
so what I'm going to do is commit what
we've done so far and then pull in
Sebastian's pull request and then
because it looks it looks good now so we
might as well just pull that in and then
it should make it easier to do what
we're trying to do right now so I'm not
going to commit the change I made to
have an grok work so let's go get add
and we're just going to add this views
post detail
okay if you're not familiar with github
basically what we did was we added this
file and then once you added is ready to
commit we committed it and then we added
a commit message then with this git push
origin master we sent that change up to
the master branch on github now I can
merge let's double check and make sure
there's no conflicts I'm going to
refresh this okay good I didn't think
there would be but always get to double
check you're gonna merge that great I'm
going to leave a great very grateful
message
alright now let's pull that change in
great
and
yet let me pull this off the page for
now let's see okay awesome all right so
we have this this is pretty good I'll
probably end up messing with the size a
little bit but basically this is this is
pretty much it so I guess right now if
anybody really wants something that
would work on something to work on and
all I'll make these into issues most
likely but the category what I would
like is if we click the category it
would have the same effect as clicking
the category on the side here so that
you could easily click it and then go to
that category page the category would
probably need to be a bit bigger so that
it's it's more easily clicked and seen
the date looks great I like that
with the attachments we might end up
doing with the attachments so
potentially we might just remove the
read more and then if we do that move
attachments down to here so they would
be below this dividing line probably
decrease the size of the of attachments
here and then this looks fine this looks
great the only difference that I have
for these right now is the the font
color is lighter so it's probably like
if we did like an RGB a black color it
would have the opacity of 0.5 for that's
usually what I do for that that gray
color but that's not really a big deal
that's just how I did it the last time
the way I said oh oh at some point today
or tomorrow probably make some some
issues for that okay but otherwise
really awesome job on that
that looks great so now we should be
able to see what
she'd be able to see what happened here
and yes awesome okay I was really hoping
that Sebastian did it this way I thought
he did so since he added the categories
into this post fragment what we're going
to be able to do since we're using what
we're not using the fragment here
we aren't okay I thought we were already
using the fragment for the single post
details so let's see if we can work this
fragment in into this okay so let's see
will impose the state of this fragment
let me make sure we can do this
ah you know what maybe we don't have
this edges we don't have to deal with
the edges node for a single post okay no
worries it still makes it a heck of a
lot easier because now I can just copy
this and put that right down here and
actually while we're in here let's get
rid of the author since we're not going
to be using that and let's see me tell
you what date okay just checking to see
if we could get rid of anything else
while we're in here I do want to grab
this slug do I want this load
I don't think I need this look no I
don't what I'd like to do is change
these I accidentally all right this is
fine so it's hard to see probably on
your screen but right now the post still
has this ID which is just you know a lot
of nonsense ready to us you know just a
random string but what I would like to
have is the post slug here just like we
did for the categories so if you
remember so category has the slug which
looks a lot nicer so that's what I'd
like to do for the posts as well so
should be too difficult because we've
already done it once for categories but
we will need to switch up a little bit
about how we're getting that so I'm not
going to do that right now but that that
is coming okay great so now we should be
able to grab the category so while
potentially you could have more than one
category and WordPress on a single post
I am setting the limit at one category
for our content managers so we'll never
have to worry about more than one
category here but let's go ahead and
check out our post preview and let's
bring in we're just going to bring over
exactly the same way we're doing in a
post preview we're gonna copy and paste
that over and then we can adjust it
accordingly
there we go
bring that in and I think I'm gonna
bring over some of these classes now
I'm sorry these styles I was looking for
Const classes but that's not it's in
that lorry we're getting it from okay
let me double-check yeah
alright let's bring this in now
that way it should work whoa okay
we need what's undefined you categories
not the fine classes all right let's see
we would have what I do
oh okay I see these are being passed in
as props so I can't just say category in
this case it would be you end up being
beep Oh starts
those categories categories it is that
actually let me just see how are we
passing this
area
that's what I wanted okay awesome
it's post
so we won't need this exactly but it'll
be close to that so I'm going to copy
this over
okay so we don't need node this should
work we're also gonna need to bring in
whoops miss my posts those preview keeps
going away we need to bring in some of
these colors
and let's see what else blue-gray
classes in category styles yeah we
probably need this huh
classes by
I don't know why I'm calling this
classes right I should be able to just
get it like that
okay it's kind of what we wanted step in
the right direction let's see what I did
kind of gory color
okay
let's see
all right Sebastian's explaining what's
what's going on here so he says you also
have to pass the style as props with
styles grids have export to fall West
oh okay okay
actually can we do this
how can we
all right how can I add this in and have
it work with everything else that's
going on I don't think this will work
let's try it I feel like we already
dealt with this how did we fix this last
time
okay thanks argit I know we I know I I
went through the same thing at some
point maybe it was last week
yeah which component did we do that in
yes we did
okay
okay cool all right that makes sense as
to why I didn't remember the solution
because I didn't find it how I found the
solution and fixed it in a pull request
all right so let's find where that was
let's see let's check let's check home
category
yeah
maybe we no longer have that peg
component all right okay so I did it
wrong
let's see
Oh
all right awesome sorry about that put
the the last parentheses in in the wrong
spot okay now I can put this back to
would not not here over here now I can
put this back to what it should have
been classes
what did I do
all right thanks Sebastian for for
pasting the everything in there oh okay
I see
all right thanks Sebastian so if you
can't see the live chat right now
Sebastian is just coaching me through
all of this
oops
yay all right thank you for all the help
uh-huh all right cool it works now so
it's amazing how much you forget about a
project when you haven't worked on it
for a week I've been working mostly on
react native huh the last week so works
a little bit differently
oh that cool my timer went off so it
went off a little while ago but I did
want to work through that issue before
we did question-answer so let me do a
short break and go over some of the live
chat and well I guess I'm definitely not
going to make it to the optional thing
that I had at 3 3 o'clock harsh should
ask is there any react native for us
there will be there will be more react
native I almost was going to do react
native in the stream but I just ended up
not ended up not doing it ok let's go
all right so I I found where I left off
Alexander says hey Jessie
Alexander thanks for joining us in the
last chat and it says newcomer welcome
thanks for watching thanks for joining
us in the live chat feel free to ask any
questions
see
Ryan says hey there what can I learn all
of this Brett says start with Jesse's
first project using next Jas this is
likely the deep end of the pool jack way
beyond says I had the same question
thanks for answering it yeah I mean you
could you could start there or if you go
to any we have four projects right now
so if you go to day one of any of the
four projects that would be good so if
if you didn't want to learn about next
chance and start with the first you
could probably start with day one of any
of the projects that would work also
these streams aren't really set up like
a tutorial so you may need to if you
really want to watch the streams you
probably will need to supplement with
some other stuff because they'll
definitely be some gaps you know we
don't go over every detail in every step
but you definitely get you know you'll
you'll learn some things you know as you
go along just just from kind of watching
the code and how we figure out problems
and things like that and feel free to
ask any questions that you have
you know while it while I'm streaming I
get to all the questions eventually
California boy says how long have you
been coding about five years I I have a
much more in-depth explanation of my my
coding history on my youtube channel
which i think is linked in the
description so if you check out my
youtube channel there's a video called
how I became a front-end developer so
check that video out I explain it a lot
more but the short answer is like three
to five years basically depending on how
you really want to define coder so yeah
jacobian says is there anyone willing to
join study groups I have a lot to catch
up on that's actually a great idea so
actually at this point I'm super busy
with my class and the work and
everything so I don't know that I would
be that much help in a study group right
now but that's a really good idea so if
if you are interested in forming some
type of study group I definitely I
support that and I may be able to help
out and be a part of it at some point
but definitely not until I finish my
class which shouldn't be that much
longer I should be finished in November
the course in November I also have to
give a talk at a conference and I'm
gonna have surgery on my wrist so I may
not actually be available in November
maybe to be more like late December okay
brian says it jumps in Internet Explorer
6 also talking about that UI bug ha ha
that's a good one
I like that it'd be fun to go back and
see how the sites we've worked on look
in Internet Explorer 6 if they even work
at all all right so I tell you what I
don't think I want to do a whole nother
Pomodoro session but let's let's just
start the timer at least so we can have
a cutoff point this will be the last
session no matter what but what I'd like
to do is just style this text a little
bit closer to how we want it see how
long that takes maybe adjust some of
this and make sure that we don't get
this big box here so we'll do those few
things and and then we'll finish up but
I'll answer the rest of the questions in
the live chat so let me let me do this
and I'm gonna mark where we left off in
the chat okay
so let's see let's let's just get rid of
this right now so we'll just want to
conditionally render that image so
what's going here and say
I guess I'll just copy all this because
basically what we want
oops that's not what I need what we want
isn't this and if we put it here we
won't need it
and here anymore so if you're not
familiar with this this is called let me
think it's a short circuit of something
I can't remember the exact name of it
where's Patrick I haven't seen Patrick
in the live chat for a while but I'm
pretty sure Patrick told me what the
name of this was if somebody knows that
let me know but anyway you're
short-circuiting the normal logic that's
happening here but basically it's just a
shorthand way of saying if posts if
there is post featured image then render
this so that's what now okay Harshit
said it's conditional running yeah it's
conditional rendering but when you just
do the the and here instead of like a
normal little ternary it was it's called
something about short-circuiting but I
just can't remember if there's more to
it than just saying short-circuit so
anyway basically we're doing the same
thing that we were doing in the source
but now we're doing it for the entire
component for the entire element I guess
it's not really a component so that'll
get rid of the box so let's just just
see what happens there we go okay but if
we go to something that has an image it
will display it so not bad that was an
easy fix
let's
go back to one without without the image
because then the I really want to see
the comparison of text size once we
change the font size here so I that'll
be easier if they're closer together in
this case
oh that's it all right
okay so rook rook has it here this so
basically I'm summarizing what rook has
just said in the live chat what happened
so normally when you have an end right
you'd be saying if this is true and
whatever else out here is true then do
something but basically how it works
with an and operator is if the first one
is true it never looks for the second
value because this is if one or the
other is true so it doesn't care what's
on the other side right so that's why we
can short-circuit it because in reality
right we we're not checking for a second
value so this will say well in in a
sense I shouldn't say that because if
this is false right we we do want to
check right but in the case that this is
true it'll just automatically render
that right does that make sense
yeah alright cool so in in booze Matt
sorry if I've mispronounced that but in
booze Matt says yeah if the expression
gets too and while resolving to
something fall see it just exits cool it
so anyway that's just it's kind of just
that a very concise way of writing it
and so you'll see that a lot in the
different repositories that we've been
working on so let's see alright so that
works now we need to instead of
dangerous you said enter HTML okay
how are we gonna do this I'm not sure if
we'll be able to use typography here
well we can try it out and see let's
just try it
okay it looks like Sebastian Sebastian
and horse should say you can so let's go
ahead with that and see tight oh it
looks like we can just set innerhtml
grades cool
so we don't even need that div let's
give this I'm not sure what all the type
options are but I'm assuming there's a
type option for paragraph maybe maybe we
should just check since we have the docs
open anyway let's check this out
typography here we go
typography type body okay let's call it
body 21 and do we need huh interesting
okay so we can put this component
really I we want this to be a div really
because the content that we're going to
get is already going to be formatted
with paragraph tags so let's see how
this looks
mmm okay wait a second he's gonna post
preview no nobody's face okay Sebastian
says using it in post cream you let's
see
okay Sebastian is using body to with the
gutter bottom okay
let's see if 42 makes makes it look
different
okay I see slightly different look at
font size still looks really small to me
I'm gonna check to see what the size is
here
oh yeah 14 pixels yeah I don't like that
yeah I definitely want a bigger font
size here so we may end up
we could change the typography styles
for the theme maybe we'll do that
okay so it looks like Sebastian says try
display one harsh it says try headline
okay let's let's at least try those
before we start overriding things if you
remember in our last project we use
material UI but we brought in that
responsive font all those that CSS that
changed the font size based on media
queries I actually really like that so
we may bring that in anyway but I do
want to see what these look like so
let's try what was the first one display
one let's try that out
okay much bigger yeah I don't I like
this size better than the first one but
I definitely would want a different
color and probably a different font wait
let's try this other one who was it
headline
oh okay that's actually not bad I like
that color better again I'm I'm I'm more
fond of the thinner font wait that's not
bad
let's see how that looks also with a
something with an image oh actually I
think it looks better it looks it better
with an image that's not bad okay I
think we're going to go with this for
now I'm still thinking about checking
out the maybe integrating that that font
that responsive font into here maybe
maybe I could do it in a way that like
let's say let's take that body 1 or body
2 and customize that basically override
the default styles and instead make it
have all the styles that we want from
that responsive font that way we don't
have to in our components you know add
an extra class into each one instead we
can just use body I don't know if it's
possible to make an additional one like
for instance we can make up our own type
I'm sure it's possible but I don't know
if there's a proper way to do that I
don't want to directly edit material UI
files for instance like in our node
modules folder so anyway but not bad I
think this it's not a hundred percent to
where I want it
I just want to mess I think with font
weights and sizes and maybe the coloring
just a bit but for now it's not that and
I actually I mean at this size of those
good it's still you know if we have a
large screen like this I still don't
like how how long this is so I don't
know a margin might not be a bad idea
and also I'm not sure about the image
like this if I'm gonna have I don't know
that I want a huge image that spans this
this whole way I think maybe margins are
our best bet to handle that because then
that way we don't need a big image for
it to look okay because I don't think it
looks okay like this but I don't think
it would look alright if it were just
centered and you still had this hanging
over the sides I could do with this
being perhaps a bit bigger if we if we
had some margins on the side but I don't
want the text extending beyond it hmm
not bad
okay all right I think that's that's not
bad for for today let's see we have gone
over some things so there are some
things that aren't issues yet officially
in in github but we've gone over them in
the stream so if if anybody like to make
them an issue or work on them before I
get around to officially putting them in
to our github repo then feel free to do
that and once again I I completely
understand none of you are on and under
any obligation to help out with this
project and I really really appreciate
all your time I mean these projects I
you know I know it's nice you can build
up your your github profile with with
some of this work if you know if you're
looking to to do some work on you know
some real sites that are you know that
are gonna go live or in use but I you
know I really really appreciate it so I
just don't ever want to feel like I once
you ought to feel like I expect you to
do something I don't I would still do
this dream if no one ever contributed
anything and it was all me so don't
don't feel like I I expect it right but
when it happens I'm very very
appreciative and I always learn a lot
from your code whenever you you submit
things
okay so I've scrolled back up to our
left off in the live chat I'm going to
go down and answer any questions so if
you're not interested in sticking around
for the question-and-answer session I
totally understand thanks for watching
so far and I should be back tomorrow so
hopefully I'll see you then otherwise if
you have a little bit of time I'd love
if you could hang out for a bit in the
live chat ask questions and answer
questions because I could definitely use
your expertise and helping answer some
of these questions all right so
let's see oh okay Harshit says he knows
the cause of that UI bug says it is due
to the display of y-axis scrollbar in
the drawer oh okay
but says it's but it's not that big of a
deal it's only a four to seven pixel
shift so the so let's see this this
actually makes a lot of sense that I'm
not seeing it on a Mac now so let's try
to so assuming this we talk about the
scrollbar in the drawer Macs and other
systems handle scroll bars differently
so if you're on a Windows system and it
was like this on a Mac you can't see the
scrollbar and so you actually scroll on
Windows there would be a scrollbar there
so I'm assuming that that potentially
has something to do with that
positioning and then I suppose that when
this shows up it oops it changes
something maybe it hides the scroll I'm
not really sure because I can't see it
on Windows right now I can check it out
with browser stack later on so I'll
check that out I mean you're right
Harshit it's not really that big of a
deal but if we have time we may as well
try to try to figure it out
okay harsh it says Jessie don't refer to
get as github it will surely create
confusion among the newbies yeah you're
definitely right so sorry if I if I do
that so I don't I don't remember when I
said that earlier on it was a while ago
when when horseshit brought that up but
yeah so for anybody who is new and not
familiar with git and github git is a
version control system that you can use
with or without github so github is a
website where people put their git
repositories so that you can other
people can see them browse them look at
the code and easily submit pull requests
and in clone repositories so there is a
big difference between github and get so
if I mess up and say github when I
should be saying get please call me out
on that so I can correct it and I don't
want to confuse anyone okay a few
minutes ago when I said if you can't
stick around for the chat then you know
feel free to go I guess a lot of people
took me up on that offer because right
after that the viewership just drunk
let's see and use this as a lager one
hey how's it going thanks for joining us
Satya as are you learning react native
from Udacity yes I am so the Udacity
nano degree takes you through three
projects the first project is just basic
react with reactor Otto so you choose
create react app and react router to do
a really basic react app the second
project you add in Redux it's a little
bit more complex the third project you
use react native that's what I'm working
on right now and it's an app where you
have you can make decks of flashcards
and then you can take quizzes based on
those flashcards and it gives you a
grade on how well you did
you can add flash cards to your decks so
it's actually going to be somewhat
useful I think after I make it I'll
teach my kids how to use it and they can
use it to help them study of you know
for their tests at school
let's see okay harsh it says you know
Jessie these these are all rappers use
higher-order components for passing
props let's see I made one in Maya fun
ocation blog I'm trying to follow the
see if there's anything left okay yeah
okay cool yeah hard [ __ ] I haven't
really looked into how this particular
version of material UI does everything
so yeah so I'm not super familiar with
what's going on behind the scenes but
I'm sure after I use it this is the
first project that I ever use it on this
this particular version of material UI
so sure after I work with it for a
little while longer I'll get used to how
everything how everything's supposed to
work
Harshit says start from learn codecademy
channel i started from there yeah I'm
I'm not sure somebody must have asked
about learning react or something like
that anyway yeah I definitely recommend
that channel as well so that's one of my
top channels for learning more about
react or JavaScript in particular so the
videos a lot of the videos are kind of
old but the the basic principles are
still really good
so that's will Stearns YouTube channel
learn code Academy I learned so much
with that a couple years ago when I was
really trying to learn more about
JavaScript I watched a horse that's
handled quite a bit Nisar says favour us
by react native with expo only no native
development for us with Windows OS yeah
yeah we're not right now I'm working
with Expo and react native we're
definitely not going to do native
development will stick with JavaScript
I'm still learning in JavaScript and
want to focus on that so I won't be
switching it up with with anything else
right now Hubley blake slate he was
building a desk
let's go that sounds cool I'm building a
desk is it a nice desk let's see
okay I got to the bow on the live chat
Blake's asking about the end rock link
so I am gonna pass this in Blake I'm
gonna paste this in I mean the end rock
link and I'll leave it running for a
little while I'll shut it down before I
leave today so even if I end the stream
you'll be able to check it out for a
little while so here's that link cool
harsh it says we are happy to contribute
is nice get featured in the stream
oh cool well I'm glad you're happy and
actually I totally forgot about that
I guess it is kind of cool to get to get
featured on the stream for free code
camp so yeah definitely I it anyone that
contributes at some point I will thank
you on the stream and make I try to make
a big deal about it so let's see Blake
says yes I'm building at my local
woodworking guild they have classes for
youth cool says okay I don't need long
maybe 20 minutes all right cool yeah but
I'll definitely leave that anger out
link up for 20 minutes maybe more that's
pretty cool that that you're doing some
woodworking stuff I I used to be more
into building things like doing some
construction work and things but I've
just been way too busy for it now and
after I I tore some ligaments in my
wrist I really shouldn't be using it
that much so I haven't haven't done much
building recently okay issue screenshot
oh great so harsh it has taken a
screenshot of the issue I'm assuming
that this is that UI bug let me take a
look at that right now and see if I can
put that
oh okay great let's see so let me bring
this over so here it is so you can see
the the logout is is open there and
bulletin is right up against there yes
so that's definitely definitely not how
it should look so you know it's only a
very specific case when that would
happen okay all right that's cool I'll
try to okay and this is actually on a
Mac and this this looks like from one of
my interesting I wonder why I can't get
it to to happen hmm I mean I am in
Chrome Canary
so I guess but potentially I could try
it give it a shot whoa what's going on
it's
okay something must have been cashed all
right since I still can't recreate it
oh well I'll figure it out at some point
Oh
Harshit said it was a loon - okay that
was weird it it had I did it had on the
other side I thought I saw that it had
the the icon for for Mac it had the
Apple er anyway okay so that makes more
sense
okay so it's the Apple theme for Linux
alright that makes more sense all right
cool I should be able to recreate it if
I just run it on using browser stack
I'll run it on a Windows Windows machine
so let's see I think that's it I think
I've covered everything in the live chat
if I miss your question I apologize so
you know you can ask me again the next
time I stream or send me a message on
Twitter or something and I'd be happy to
answer your question you can also write
you know put a comment on this video as
well I don't think quite as good of a
job of getting back to all the comments
because that I have a lot of videos it's
kind of hard to track it down
and especially since there's so many
other people contributing this channel
sometimes it's hard to sift through the
comments on all the other videos so
sometimes they get lost and I don't even
realize they're there because they get
so far down the list before I even get a
chance to check so if you've commented
on a video and I haven't responded it's
probably because that's happened and
it's gotten lost you know buried and all
the rest of the comments so I'm not
purposely ignoring it I probably just
never saw it and sometimes I do try to
go back but there I actually don't know
how many videos I've done I haven't
counted so but there are a lot so it's
quite a bit to look through so so if you
really need to answer to something you
know send me a direct message on some
form of social media and that's probably
the the surest way to get get the answer
so
all right oh yes I should says is is
requesting that I merge PR 39 it'll
solve the male issues okay cool I'll
check it out I can't guarantee I'll
merge PR 39 today because to be honest
with you I've already I'm already over
my my work time for today so I'm into I
don't get paid extra for overtime and
I'm into overtime so I'm probably gonna
try to leave soon and I just got a text
from my wife that I gotta run to the
store and pick up a bunch of stuff oh so
I'm gonna be a I gotta go to run some
errands but tomorrow morning I should be
able to I don't I don't have any
meetings tomorrow morning so I should be
able to get everything merged and then
alright awesome so anyway this was a
good stream didn't really get in
anything too difficult you know just
some basic stuff but it was a nice
stream and definitely enjoyed you know
talking with you all and I should like I
said it should be back tomorrow probably
around 2:00 we'll see I'll schedule I'll
try to schedule the stream a little bit
earlier in the day I know today was
somewhat short notice I don't think I
got a scheduled until less than an hour
before I came on so I'd like to give you
a little bit more of notice tomorrow if
I can
but until then for for everybody
celebrating what was that I don't want
to mess it up
Diwali is that I think that's that's
what it was that I really I don't want
to mess up the pronunciation but I have
it have a great time with that and I
will see everyone tomorrow